Yes, brother. Corruption. Corruption.
Good. I've got the police in my pocket.
Police can't catch me. I'm a big bad,
right? Corruption. Police cannot catch
me because police is on my payroll.
Corruption is good for me. Corruption is
good for me now. Not good for you. You
don't drop. Good for me. Corruption is
good. I've got the police in my pocket.
I've got the ministers in my pocket.
You're right. All these on my payroll.
All these police and ministers they on
my payroll
I rob and I give them some share they
very happy with me good or bad good okay
now we will turn the tables over okay no
one could give me one logical reason why
it is bad for a top mafia you have
reason okay last last try
one day I will die so
>> you as a robber there's one day that
you'll die and Everything will be
accounted the day of kyama. That is
this person forgot the rules.
He doesn't understand English.
If you don't believe in God, how do you
believe in kama?
I'm talking to a non-Muslim. You are
behaving as a non-Muslim. Talking to a
Muslim.
Okay. You are a non-Muslim
who's trying to convince a person who's
also not a non-Muslim. Who's also a
non-Muslim who doesn't believe anything?
You don't believe. We don't believe. Now
we will turn the tables over. You are
that big robber. Okay. Who's a
non-Muslim? Now I'm Zakin D. Not not
robber. Correct. Now we'll turn the
tables over. We'll switch sides.
Correct. You are the top mafia all of
you and you have to give the same answer
what I give you. For example, if I tell
you
that
you should not rob because the man who
has robbed will suffer. You will tell me
so what they he's suffering. I'm not
suffering. If I tell you police will
catch you, you tell me police is in my
pocket. They on my payroll. The
ministers are in my payroll. I agree
with you. If I tell you, if I tell you
that if you rob,
if you rob, it's against humanity. You
will tell me who wrote this book called
humanity? Mahatma Gandhi, who wrote it?
I don't care
if it tells you that the man that you
have robbed,
he will suffer. It it makes no
difference. You are enjoying life. Now
what you have to understand you are
logical.
Now in logic normally you are very
powerful. You are number one mafia and
you think no one is superior to you.
That's the reason you think no one can
rob you. Correct? You think no one can
arrest you because you're number one.
But the basic rule is that anyone who
does injustice on others would never
want injustice to be done to him.
But because you're powerful, you think
no one can do injustice to you. Correct?
So I speak to you about the concept of
Allah, the existence of Allah subhanana
wa tala. I've given a talk on does God
exist? And with the help of the Quran, I
prove to you the existence of Allah
subhananaa tala.
That'll take 1 hour. Time doesn't
permit. You see my video cassette. So
once you logically hear my talk, does
God exist? You'll start believing in
God. Okay. Now once you believe in God,
okay, I agree God is this. So what
today you find, okay, now you as a
non-Muslim start believing in God. But
then you tell me what is the use of this
God. We see so many people who rob,
lead a good life and they die. Some are
arrested, some are caught, many go
scotfree. Right or wrong? Right or
wrong? Many people, you know, they are
robbers. YOU KNOW THEY ARE CORRUPT.
CORRUPTION.
You know many ministers who cheat, who
take money, but they lead a good life
and they die. So what kind of a god is
this? Allah says in the Quran in surah
nisa chapter 4 verse number 40 Allah is
never unjust in the least degree. Allah
is never unjust in the least degree.
Allah also says in surah mul chapter
number 67 verse number two
Allah has created death and life to test
which of his good indeeds. I will tell
you that Allah also says in surah Iran 3
verse 185
every soul shall have a taste of death
BUT THE FINAL RECOMPENSE will be on the
day of judgment.
Anyone who has saved from the hellfire
and enters Jenna has achieved the
objective of this life. For this life is
nothing but mere play and amusement.
Yeah. Allah is telling you, you are a
new person who started believing in God.
Now I'm telling you Allah is never
unjust in the in the least degree. Allah
also say this life is a test for the
hereafter. Allah says in surah Iran
chapter 3 verse 185 final judgment
is on the day of judgment. That means if
you do something wrong you may get
punishment in this world you may get in
bak may get in A TOTAL ALL THREE PUT
TOGETHER is correct maybe Allah will not
give you any punishment in this world
Allah may not give you any punishment IN
BARAK FULL PUNISHMENT in a correct so
the full justice this life is temporary
an average human being live for about 70
75 years correct
I some may live for 80 90 the next world
is eternal.
So this life is a short span. Allah is
telling the final recompense is yay
in the